>From the last problem, we found out there is an infinite number of solutions to
this inequality. We know a way to write those answers. And, I don't want to list
them out because that could be tedious. So, let's use a solution set. A solution
set is all the answers to this inequality. To find them, we solve this
inequality just like we solve an equation. We subtract 2 from both sides to get
3 x is greater than 6. Then, we divide both sides by the coefficient in front of
the variable, we divide by 3. And the answer is x is greater than 2. So, any
number larger than 2 will make this inequality true. Let's use the solution set
to write our answer. We can show the solution in two ways. We can use a number
line or interval notation. We use an open parentheses at x equals 2 because x
can't actually equal 2, its got to be bigger than 2. And then, we draw an arrow
in the direction of the numbers that are all bigger than 2. 2 is considered to
be the lower bound of our solution set. We use an open parentheses for 2 so that
we don't include it. We can remember, because is we plug in 2 here, we'll get 8
greater than 8, which isn't true. So, we don't include 2 in the solution. We use
an open parenthesis for positive infinity because we can't actually reach
infinity. Any number bigger than 2 will work. You might be used to seeing an
open circle at 2, which is correct. For this class, though, we'll only use the
parenthesis when showing answers on the number line.